now thank you for staying with us here
at 4 30 I'm Denise Valdez and I'm
Vanessa Murphy multiple large-scale
events to honor the Jewish faith are
planned across the valley this weekend
but it comes after multiple incidents
deemed anti-semitic a swastika allegedly
carved into an autistic and Jewish
teenager is just the latest example
that's provoking more security eight
news now reporter Ryan Matthey has the
extra measures extra measures that are
being taken
it's a busy weekend for the Las Vegas
Jewish Community here at the El Cortez
for example a pop-up Shabbat expecting
to bring hundreds of Jewish people
collectively the organizers for that and
other events this weekend saying they
need extra security to combat
anti-Semitism our services are
constantly being patrolled and and
people are being looked after because
you just never know Southern Nevada
temples say they've been increasing
security more so within the past year
from anti-jewish flyers in Boulder City
to a swastika allegedly carved into an
autistic and Jewish teenager at a school
just a few reasons why the
Anti-Defamation League recorded 30
anti-semitic incidents in Nevada during
2022. we also have extra patrols but the
threats aren't breaking tradition
congregation near to Mid would Temple
Sinai celebrating the Jewish day of rest
this Friday in a public way upwards of
300 people in downtown Las Vegas at a
pop-up Shabbat for oaking five times the
amount of security they typically would
hire then on Sunday at Craig Ranch
Amphitheater up to 1800 people expected
to celebrate 75 years of Israel's
independence secure Community Network
Nevada telling 8 news now in a statement
that notifications have been made to
federal law enforcement with local and
state patrols scheduled to be on site
Friday and Sunday organizers like Temple
Sinai spiritual leader Heather Klein
says it's necessary to combat hate and
live outwardly Jewish I think with the
rise of anti-Semitism I think we just
don't have a choice I think it's
absolutely something we have to do and
it's better to be safe than sorry